welcome everybody for our last day of
pi data eindhoven 2020
so this last day or friday we
kick off with a very amazing speaker
adam from nvidia
he has prior experience in self
driving cars and also with the uk
government
and he now has a very interesting
job at nvidia and
you'll tell us more about the rapids
package actually i at the luxury
of discussing the talk beforehand with
him
and we had such a lot of interesting
topics that we could be presenting about
and this one was my personal uh favorite
um so adam the floor is all yours
so yes thank you kindly for the kind
introduction so
today i'll be talking about rapids you
know rapids is effectively
a set of libraries that provide seamless
gpu acceleration for traditional
data science pipeline so hopefully
you'll find it interesting
and it's quite impactful as you'll see
and because of the
order of magnitude of acceleration
my name is adam i'm a senior deep
learning scientist at nvidia and in a
nutshell
i'm an applied mathematician and i help
companies build and deploy machine
learning based
products over the last five years i've
been focusing predominantly
on neural networks but still working
with
more classical algorithms as well
uh a quick agenda so today we'll talk
about rapids
uh and in particular we'll try to
dive slightly deeper into the library's
builder lovers namely kudevka
mlc graphql and hopefully by the end of
the talk i'll show you how you can take
your existing codes today
and within with just a couple of lines
of code change
in migrated to rapids but
let's dive into that a bit deeper later
so as i mentioned
rapids is just a set of open source
libraries
which give you the option the freedom to
execute your
entire data science pipeline from data
loading and
through machine learning and
visualization entirely on the gpu
yes i'm not sharing the screen am i
of course i'm not sorry i didn't miss
much just my
face on the slide
how about now perfect
okay so here we go
so that's that's the slide that you've
and the one with the agenda
so rapid is a set of open source
libraries that allow you to execute end
student pipeline
so from the data loading through any
form of augmentation
teacher extraction through machine
learning up to analytics entirely on the
gpu
and when we've been designing rapids we
were
quite aware that what we shouldn't do is
to build
yet another ecosystem of utilities
as we there exists a very well
established set of tools within this
data science space and what we wanted to
achieve
is to create something that will gpu
accelerate them
not necessarily create yet another
utility that data scientists have to use
as a consequence
wherever possible our ambition was to
maintain
the api that those existing very well
established libraries
introduce the library such as pandas
psychic layer network x
map plot clip plotty or
whenever possible integrate with other
well established utilities such as
pythonx and tensorflow
also we were aware that it's not really
possible to build
this library based just on a single gpu
that is why we
have chosen to use dusk as a mechanism
for distribution so what we'll be
discussing today are the following
libraries which is a drop-in
replacement of pandas by dropping
replacement again i mean
we were trying to maintain the api so
that you don't have to change your code
uml which is intending to be a drop in
replacement of psychic learn and
exegboost
to graph which is intended to be a drop
in replacement of network x
and we were working hard on integration
with other utilities such as spirit
pythog mx tensorflow as well as
create a gpu accelerated visualization
toolkits and i'll discuss some of them
such as qx filter
cloud data as well it's this is not the
entirety of the tools
that that rapids is providing but i'll
focus predominantly on those today
there are also other utilities some of
them i'll mention very briefly like
who's spatial for spatial data or coup
signal for
signal processing time series data but
um
if you're interested in those reach out
to me after the talk on linkedin
and i'm happy to give you information
about them and
get you going okay
so um so our
goal as i mentioned earlier was to
create same
wherever possible or at least very
familiar python api
that requires that allows you to migrate
your existing cpu-based code
with either no or very low code change
to be entirely executed on a gpu and
lastly we have achieved it a very large
proportion of code and we migrate it
into rapids with just the change of
the import statement so you effectively
whenever you do
import pandas you would change that to
qdf and your code
largely will work obviously those
libraries are very mature so we don't
integrate the entirety of their api but
i'll show you um how flexible rapids is
and how easy it is to move between
rapids and pandas
so you'll see that that makes it that
has
very little impact if any at all okay so
in today's talk i'll focus on the key
components of graphics not all of them
qdf so gpu accelerated
data preparation and feature engineering
library yes
effectively dropping the replacement for
pandas 2ml
gpu accelerated machine learning library
including xgboost and quite a wide range
of other
utilities we'll go through the detailed
list in a second
graph a a gpu accelerated graph
analytics library qx filter
with a web data visualization library so
effectively
gpu accelerated cross filter and
couple others so we will at least
mention spatial signal
there are a couple of components that
make
rapids behind the scenes and
as a data scientist you typically don't
have to
care about them but it's good to know
that they exist so
in rapids is built entirely
upon apache arrow data representation
and it's a columnar data layout so
whenever you use rapids your data will
be stored stored in a columnar fashion
and its emphasis is on minimizing data
movement
whenever possible as you might be aware
data movement is one of the most
expensive parts
when dealing with gpu compute and there
is so much computational power that
typically the data movement becomes your
major bottleneck that's why it was very
important for us to optimize that
process
so in we have chosen apache arrow
because hey
it's very broadly used and we'll see it
in the next slide
how deep integration with other
utilities it allowed us to create
and it really handles memory with a lot
of get
in the majority of cases we can move
the data between different processes
even between different programs
with zero copy or
at most a very shallow copy
of data to minimize the overhead relay
and we've maintained consistency with
the cpu version
and and this allows us this seamless
integration between tools and
this is the foundation for that seamless
integration also with pandas
excited learn to so that you can have
parts of your code written in a
classical way
and parts of your code executed no
problem
by choosing apache arrow we've managed
to almost for free obtain integration
with a very broad ecosystem of other
utilities
pandas and you'll see how seamless it is
in a second
and a very broad range of other
utilities already take advantage of
apache arrow
and this allows us to minimize the
overheads
related to unnecessary serialization and
deserialization as well as data movement
for gpu accelerated libraries we
typically
they don't even have to copy the data we
can just pass the pointer to it
passing on the computation and
gpus are also so fast and we'll discuss
how significantly faster than their cpu
implementation
they are that in fact we have to also
look at other bottlenecks in the
execution process
namely networking and by networking i
don't necessarily mean the networking
connecting computers
in in your in your data center
because a lot of users might not be
executing in a data center at all
and might not have jobs which are large
enough but also
networking within the node that is why
rapids is also
tightly integrated with open ucx that
allows us to use a very broad range of
technologies
to allow exchange of data between the
gpus
we are aware that a lot of problems will
be larger than the memory footprint of a
single gpu and with open ucx we
can build very large gpu systems that
from the perspective of a user
behave as one extremely large gpu
and this is achieved because ucx not
only supports basic protocols like tcp
but also can support in infiniband and
shared memory technologies
so it can it supports a technology that
we've introduced called the gpu direct
rdma
where gpus can exchange memory between
each other not bothering
the cpu and talking to each other
directly
and this itself has a fairly dramatic
impact
so what you were seeing here is not a
comparison of code executed on cpu
versus a gpu
but a code executed on a gpu on
gpus several gpus with tcp as a backbone
for communication and ucx and
as you can see we see orders of
magnitude acceleration
on top of what the what the gpu is
providing
so effectively rapids it has two
major scaling components you can it
allows you to scale up
so it allows you to scale up your
existing pi data code
by just running rapids on a a
on an accelerator which is dramatically
faster than
what the modern cpus have to offer for
this workload
but it also allows you to scale out
because we've built
it entirely with with the dusk in mind
and all of the operations that are
available on a single gpu
and also in a fairly transparent way be
executed
in across really a very large number of
gpus
by taking advantage of rapid dust with
open ucx integration
okay so let's dive into its individual
components
and let's do it in say chronological
order
starting with cuda data frame so cuda
data frame
pdf provides you access to gpu access
related etl utilities
and for those of you that ever tried uh
do feature engineering uh you'll know
that
it just takes time especially when your
data sets get larger
and you need to properly validate the
the impact your
your code has on the engine pipeline
you'll know that
the etl process can very frequently
dominate
your day yes so rather than spending
time on
things that matter so building new
features and
making changes to your models you spend
time waiting for the results of the etl
even if you have a quite substantial
amount of computational resources
so we've spent a lot of time building
qdf to try to alleviate that
accelerated to the best of our ability
and this is not a library that was built
from scratch
it's built on top of a very solid
foundation
so cuda is the library which is more
than a decade old which
is a backbone for compute on the gpu
buddha data frame is built with cuda
libraries and it primarily
is built using c plus and exposed vs
item
to you as a python api
okay currently there are two main
libraries that you should care about
could a data frame and
dusk with a data frame if you want to
distribute that data frame across
multiple gpus
so some vocabulary so throughout the
stock i will be predominantly referring
to qdf
and qdf is a python library for
manipulating gpu data frames
and it's built on top of leap udf which
is the c
plus plus this counterpart that directly
accesses cuda but you very rarely need
to care about it
as you want to extend korea
which hopefully won't have to
but how to use it uh
it's fairly simple so what you're seeing
here are two snippets of code
one written in pandas and one written in
codia
as you can see they are not that
interesting because they are largely
identical the only thing we have changed
we've changed the import statement and
we've obviously changed the reference to
the library which
which we didn't have to do if we would
import it pandas in a slightly different
way
but but here you go what is what has
changed is the execution speed
yes if you will pay attention to the
numbers
by making this small change and
obviously equipping your
system with a gpu you've suddenly
accelerated
just the loading process by 16 times
yes and this is loading of a 2 gigabyte
csv file
and you will see even potentially higher
accelerations when dealing with data in
a columnar format
because by definition no conversion will
be required
we're also working very hard and that
will come up very shortly
on a technology called gpu direct
storage
and gpu direct storage will allow us to
totally ignore the cpu
when reading the files from your disk
and just pull them directly from the
disk
so the the gpu after obviously getting
a blessing from the operating system
will
fetch the files from the disks hopefully
on the same pci express
bus directly without um requiring this
cpu intervention which is
big because when you want to load the
data
fast the cpu can actually
be quite busy as a consequence of
reading files so you're bringing all of
those cpu resources
to do something else and you
dramatically shortcut
the the the access to the data so
stay tuned for that that should be
coming out quite soon and
early versions are already available
[Music]
what to expect from qdf
in terms of the speed
of execution it will vary depending
first of all on
how much data are you processing and
gpus
if you never work with them are to some
extent counter-intuitive
because the more data you give them
the more performance they get they are
so called single instruction multiple
data devices
so they feel very comfortable when the
volume of data
is large so what i'm presenting here
is speed when executing three different
data operations in on a 10
million row data set in blue
and a hundred million row data set
and the unit here is not the execution
time but it's acceleration
with respect to the state-of-the-art cpu
so so typically this merge operation
on 10 million rows will be about 500
times faster
than its fundus equivalent on a fairly
decent
canvas cpu but when we
increase the data size by 10 volt it
will be about a thousand times faster
than its counterpart executed in a cpu
the mileage will vary depending on the
operation in in
a good heuristic the more work you give
the gpu
the more performant it will be with
comparison to the
cpu if you bottlenecked on something
else
then you will see less acceleration but
still even for less
in less optimal operations
you'll see a couple hundred times
acceleration
this is not percentage this is a speed
up so this is 360 times faster not
3.6 times faster
and we're comparing here a single
voltage gpu
to a single intel xeon cpu
with 2.4 2.2
but bear in mind kudif is still quite
young
right now with we're at release 0.16 so
you should expect
further acceleration so what this slide
shows you is the progress that we've
made
between versions o10 and o13
you can see that for merge we've moved
from 870x speed up to 970 speed up
for grouped by from 150 speed up to 290
speed up and
there is still much much more work that
we need to do so you should expect
further
further improvements in performance on
exactly the same hardware
and let's show a couple examples for
those of you that know pandas they will
be hopefully boring that was our
intention
do not create another learning curve
those are just four different ways to
create a
a codif data frame this is an example of
how to create a cuda data frame just
as is from the data loaded directly from
the code
and this is an example of how to create
a similar data frame but with three
columns or that one
this is an example of how to create it
by reading a csv
file and this is an example and i i'll
focus here for a second
of how to make seamlessly migrate the
data to and from
existing cpu-based libraries so
in this example we load the data into
pandas
for reasons that might be important to
you
maybe you might not be able to change
this this line of code for
some some reasons and in this line we
just execute from pandas migrating all
of that data to the gpu and from this
point on
you can continue executing in a gp
similarly as you can imagine apart from
from pandas we have a routine called
two pandas through which you can return
the execution to your existing
so even if you don't want to migrate the
entirety of your code and that might be
a
you might have valid reasons for that
typically what we do
is we profile the code we focus on the
first couple of lines that have the
biggest
impact on the execution time and we
migrate only those
we validate and we do it again that way
we can
create the biggest impact and
change here we go
again couple more examples this time
working with the gpu data frame and
again hopefully you'll find them
very familiar this is just a head a
command
that will show you the first three rows
of the data again identical syntax
this is a this is a command for finding
mean a standard deviation of a column
again identical syntax to what you would
expect
and this is in this is
an example of map with a custom function
and again it's an identical syntax
this is a row slicing function
again identical syntax to what you would
expect
then this is a function to count the
values and find the unique values
in a particular column and an example of
how to change the data
so the reason i'm showing you those
examples is to once again stress
that wherever possible we've been trying
to not change the syntax
and if you organize your code in a
correct way in the sense that
you have some you don't refer to pandas
directly but you just
centralize it in the import statement
you might be able to change your entire
code
which is a change of the input
again examples of query sort group and
join operations
so again query syntax identical to what
you might expect
and similarly sorting and
one-hot coding aggregating data
and joining the data has identical
syntax what you
would expect from your existing library
so please consider using qdf
it will save you a lot of time
even the most trivial operations will
execute substantially faster than
your existing code and you'll be able to
focus on something else
and let's move now to qml qml is
effectively a library that is supposed
to achieve the same
but for your machine learning part of
the pipeline and
so it's supposed to be a drop in
replacement for utilities such as
psychic learning
and xg again the way it's designed it's
very similar
it's not built from scratch it's built
on top of a very well established
libraries so huda and a wider set of
buddha libraries such as
trust up crew solver and the graph
a lot of those libraries used for
decades in the scientific community
uh we didn't want to build it directly
on top of those libraries instead we've
created another library that you might
find very interesting
called oml primitives rims
where majority of the code resides bear
in mind
when we've been migrating in
machine learning libraries is much more
difficult than migrating
loading libraries in a sense that a lot
of algorithms in this space
are not inherently parallel so in a lot
of cases we have to reinvent their
implementation
so hopefully you find those primitives
quite useful if you want to build some
more complex functionality
that goes beyond the existing machine
learning utilities
existing machine learning algorithms on
top of that we've created a c plus plus
based library called uml
algorithms that captures all of the
algorithms that we support
and that is exposed via sight and usa
udf
uh qml interface and task uml interface
for
distributed execution
as of september 2020
version 0.15 and i think just literally
days ago o16 was released but this is
largely the same
those were the key algorithms that we've
supported plus a extra boost but i'll
focus on xgboost7
so how to read this table we
don't have the same implementation
across all of the algorithms quite yet
so all of the algorithms listed here
have a single gpu implementation
meaning that your data plus any
intermediate intermittent
structures need to fit within the memory
of a single gpu
a large proportion of
algorithms has a multi-gpu
implementation meaning that if you have
say
four gpus in your desktop or eight gpus
in your server
or 16 gps in your server that algorithm
will execute across all of the gpus
within that server
and it will do it seamlessly so you
don't have to really care about it all
that much
and also a subset of them has multi-node
and multi-gpu implementation and that
means that
if you have say two servers and
obviously if they have enough network
between them
then those anchors will execute on all
of the gpus within that cluster so if
you have say
32 gpus across two servers
those algorithms will automatically take
advantage of all of them
by the end of this year we're hoping to
not necessarily increase the number of
algorithms
and unless we hear from you that that is
really needed
and we're really responding to to to
your future requests on git
so if you're working with rapids that's
the best way
of communicating with us we always have
someone watching
so by the end of this year we're not
necessarily planning to extend the list
of the gpus
but try to focus on filling the gaps in
this table
so more and more algorithm algorithms
will gain multi gpu and multi-node
support
especially multi gpu is important a lot
of users
with problems that are just bigger than
30 to 40 gigabytes that you'll find in a
single
again in terms of syntax it should be
fairly familiar so what you're seeing
here is a scikit-learn
a pca implementation versus
qml based implementation
to simplify and to focus on qml we've
left the
data loading parts the same so we load
in both cases using
a classical utilities pandas
we need to add additional line of code
to move the data
from pandas into cuda data frame
and then the syntax is for pca is
identical
and so we fit transform x
what is not identical is the execution
time because on a
fairly on a fairly modern
server-based cpu so intel xeon e52686
this snippet of code would take about a
minute so 57 seconds
on a gpu this snippet of code will take
you about four seconds
4.28 seconds so a fairly dramatic
acceleration
and that acceleration spawns beyond
beyond um and beyond
just a principal component analysis what
you're seeing here is a comparison of a
single gpu
so volta v100 to two
20 core cpus we have two tables here
because
there are some those algorithms are
quite lightweight and they have low
memory footprint so we can
fit very large data frames
with them so this is a comparison of one
million two million and four million
row operation where four million row
operation
is not present that means that it didn't
fit in the
memory of that single gpu this is a 16
gigabyte variant
so again the units is the speed up over
those two
20 core cpus so this single gpu will be
about 120 times faster than those 220
core
um cpus and for linear regression about
69 times faster than those two
20 core cpus then 46 22 12
65 so the mileage will vary depending on
what you're executing
the acceleration will be dramatically
higher for algorithms that are
computationally heavy
and so as you can see the more
computationally heavy algorithm the
higher acceleration
and in this case we achieved 730x speed
up but this is not percent
this is seven times seven hundred times
faster
than its cpu counterpart xg boost
is a very important algorithm right now
for the community
it seems to be the tool of choice for a
very broad range of problems
and so we from day one had an xg boost
implementation in rapids in fact
that implementation is available in
xgboost so even if you don't want to use
rapist even if you use
exclusively xd boost that code is there
for
you to use you just have to change one
flag
and it's tuned for extreme performance
so what you think is a comparison of
a single server here with
with 16 gpus to 100 cpu servers
and we that single server will be about
10 times faster
roughly than those 100 cpu servers so do
consider using it you'll save yourself a
lot of time
and again that's not something that is
that is finished there are still more
work to be done we're working on a very
broad range of optimizations
so what you're seeing here is a
comparison of rapids 0.2 and 0.10
and and the differences in speeds are
quite substantial
and we also are aware that machine
learning is not exclusively training
but it's also inference so we're also
supporting in
forest inference library and that you
can use to deploy
those trained models to production and
again those will be about an order of
magnitude faster
than the then the cpu counterpart
and so you know this means that you can
buy 20 times less servers
to serve your model or 30 times less
servers save your model so
no no no not a trigger improvement a
similar
a story is for cool graph i will not go
into the
details but again we're not building
from scratch we're building on unknown
foundations and you can fit
very large graphs on gpus so
on a single gpu with 32 gigs of memory
500 million edges no problem on multi
gpu
billions of edges
[Music]
we need to keep the time in mind a bit
and
we do want to do some two questions from
the audience if that's okay with you
so they are both related to pandas so
you mentioned there's a
uh ninety percent uh of the panda
functionality
are already uh in so um
yeah what things are uh still not in
sobot and uh functionalities you haven't
had
yet a lot of stuff is not in and so
those are all very large libraries and
we we are not planning to just rewrite
all of them from day one
we're we're following the request from
our customers
we have a very simple approach we're
observing the git repository we're
working
with a very large number of lighthouse
account users and we're
accelerating them one by one if
something is not there
please reach out and get describe why is
it important and our team will pick it
up
hopefully within a couple of sprints
they'll be able to add
i don't have an exact list a lot of
stuff
is implemented but a lot of stuff is not
and then the second question
are you aware of any panda
functionalities that you'll probably
never take into the package no i don't
think so
we we don't think like that we we don't
know what is needed and what is not
needed you need to tell us
uh we are not all knowing yeah
yeah so whatever is needed you'll fix
basically
yeah because effectively we don't know
what the entire world
is doing so we're really responding
to to to feature requests if we get a
feature request that is well
motivated and we can understand why
people need it we typically put it into
sprint
song okay cool well thanks for the
amazing talk
let's switch to the discord channel if
you can please share also the links to
the tutorials
i think they will be very interesting
and i think we have a couple of other
questions that we
can discuss in the discord channel yep
okay
so thank you very much